hello believe nation welcome to another
edition of the evan carmichael show i
believe in entrepreneurs and i want your
business to be a success that's what
this show is all about now today i'm
coming to you live on location for those
of you watching on the video stream you
can see the big dell logo behind me i'm
i'm at dell's headquarters we're doing a
twitter chat after the show and i said i
can only come in if you let me do the
radio show from your office because i
can't miss out on talking to my people
so i'm excited to be here now today's
show is really really really important
okay we are talking about
sales
now so many entrepreneurs have you know
a great product a great service you're
you're putting everything you have into
it you're proud of what you're making
you're saying i have a great offering
here but i'm not getting the results
that i want yeah you know i'm not
getting the sales that i need and i
remember being in that position i was
the guy making 300 a month and
and you know i just pounded away on my
on my ego on my self-worth feeling like
man
i should be doing better than this what
is happening and
you know the product the service is is
definitely a key component to it you
need to have a great offering but you
also need to know what you're doing on
the sales side so today i'm talking
about how do you make the perfect sales
pitch what are the elements how do you
make it happen so that people want to do
business with you people want to spread
the word about you
and later in the show i also have a
special guest expert on with me dave
curlin he's one of the nation's top
experts on sales processes uh so we'll
be chatting with him and getting his
advice
let's get going on the pitch okay guys
you need to be different okay if you're
an average company selling an average
product at an average price guess what
happens
average results at best you need to find
a way to stand out
in my first software company we had the
easiest to use and nicest looking
product on the market okay we didn't
have the most features we didn't have
the longest track record but if somebody
wanted easy and pretty we were the place
to go we were the best at that and when
we promoted our company we talked about
the ease of use and our customers they
knew us for that it's an easy pitch to
make to our customers and they could
quickly identify if we were going to be
a fit for them or not you know not but
not everybody's going to be your
customer not everybody was our customer
some people needed lots of extra
features and we didn't offer that and
that's okay because we didn't waste our
time on those potential customers and
they didn't waste their time either
because we knew it wasn't going to be a
match that clarity helped everybody when
you're different when you're specific
people not only understand if you're
going to be able to help them but they
can also quickly tell their friends
about you right they can pass your name
on because they understand what you do
and how you're different so let me give
you an example okay say somebody asks
you what you do right it comes up all
the time so what do you do
you say well i'm a website designer
man you just missed a major opportunity
because there are hundreds of thousands
of website designers maybe millions of
website designers out there what's so
special about you i need to know
quickly what makes you different because
right now you're boring
instead you may say something like this
uh you know we're website design company
we help manufacturers with over 10
million in sales who are frustrated with
their online lead generation we help
them get a consistent stream of new
business from their website and our
clients typically see at least 20 new
leads online per month
now you're starting to get the person
thinking they're thinking am i a
manufacturing company do i know a
manufacturing company you're also now
talking about the benefits that you're
offering instead of just what you do
you're standing out it's specific it's
memorable and it dramatically improves
the chances of you getting new business
so you want to create a pitch an easy
pitch that explains who you are who you
help the benefits that they're going to
receive and you use it every time you
introduce yourself because it comes up
so often right
how often you get asked what is it that
you do and even if the person isn't a
potential client you want them to
understand what it is that you do
because they have friends and they can
talk about you so you want to make it
easy you start with a specific niche you
become the expert you know your
customers you know their problems better
than anyone else and you create custom
products and services that uniquely
solve their problems okay it's also
great to add a little bit of different
in there inject a little personality
think about what makes you different as
a person from everybody else and how you
brought that to your company again
you're looking for ways to stand out not
just be a boring company that looks and
feels like everybody else because if you
just tell me i'm a website development
company then
you know i know so many website
companies that
i'm not going to really talk to you
about it right and i can't spread the
word about you but if i know something
specific like you help manufacturers
like you help generate new leads online
you know i know if
if that's me then i can use you but if
it's not me then i can pass the word on
immediately when you tell me that i'm
thinking do i know a manufacturing
company that has that size that needs
online sales and if if i do then it's so
easy for me to pass the word on about
you okay
so for me i love helping entrepreneurs
that's my niche i get hired by big
companies and i'm here at dell today
and i help them plan their marketing
strategies because a lot of them don't
have a an idea of how to connect with
entrepreneurs
but i'm also the father of a young child
i love baseball gojs go you know next
year we'll make it i'm a salsa dance i'm
a dj you know i read up on zen i'm an
efficiency nut i ride my vespa
everywhere i wear my five toe fingers
you know i share all that and you may be
thinking well that's too much
information
but
when you inject some of your own
personality into it when you make it
personal when people feel like they're
connecting with an individual instead of
just a company you're much more likely
to get somebody interested willing to
talk to you willing to do business with
you okay so gotta make it different and
make it personal make it memorable so
when i leave a conversation with you i
know exactly what you do who you help
and how you're different that's the
start okay i want to get to the calls i
have andre on hold andre where are you
from how can i help
how you doing i'm from charlotte north
carolina and i have a dilemma um and
hopefully you'll be able to help me out
with your genius suggestion
let's hear it andre let's hear it
okay i'm a published author my book came
out in
august of this year and it kind of
surprised me because i've been writing a
blog since 2009 the blog went
international it's in like 64 countries
with like 20 000 plus readers the issue
i'm having now
is that since the book came out it sold
out twice on amazon
and i'm really having a hard time
figuring out how
to connect to my audience because the
majority of them
are international the book is what's
your date number and
when it comes to dating and stuff it's
like what i wanted to do with my book
signings and stuff anyone can go out to
dinner in a movie they're so played but
with my events when i have the book
signing seminars i want us to meet to do
fun things that people normally wouldn't
do like
zip lining or white water rafting
something that's out of the ordinary
because dating should be fun
but i just don't know how to connect to
my international audience because that's
where they are and i'm here so are you
trying to now create an events company
based off of your success with the book
and the blog
it's not necessarily an events company
as well as much as when i spoke with my
publisher about it most authors are just
kind of content with doing book signings
little festivals and stuff but i brought
an idea to them i'm like i don't want
people date to mate i want people to
date to have fun because that's what
dating should be about so whenever i
have these book signings i want us to
look in the venues that would allow us
to after the book signing do something
different so that what's your date
number could be associated with fun and
different activities but i don't know
how to do that
or to really connect with let's just say
speed dating companies or something in
my area because all of my success and
audience like i said has been overseas
so i really want that movement to catch
on here but i don't know how to start or
what to do
yeah i mean you could build it a couple
of ways a typical model for authors who
want to build up their business is a go
a consulting route a coaching route an
info product route a
you know premium website route where
there's access to you or access to more
information that's paid for that's how
most authors will go or maybe they
become a speaker maybe they have a radio
show you know they try to become that
expert instead of creating something
local
that's how most authors will go and
build up a business now if it's your
passion to create something local then
it's just starting with making the
connections to local you know dating
groups speed dating whatever it is uh
and and building that up from the ground
but it is it's going to be more work
than going the other route that more the
authors will take and trying to become
that kind of international expert but
it's where your heart is right like if
that's what you want to do you want to
connect with people local
then start it up you know start creating
a local tribe you can have your own
events or partner with local companies
to create these kind of events
um but it's really more kind of where
you want to you know where your hearts
taking you
okay
okay that's good because this thing i
was thinking about doing like you said
the the personal coach type of
venue but when i sat down and i talked
to my audience and stuff based upon some
of the questions they're like it's just
so played we do speed date where we just
kind of sit down and we just talk and we
just go out to dinner but that's so
boring so i'm trying to do something
different and kind of make a movement
around the book all right so andre how
what is your ideal day look like okay
like what do you want to do do you want
to keep writing do you want to be a
coach do you want to be do you want a
radio show you want a youtube channel
you want to do local stuff to kind of
touch and feel people what is the ideal
they look like with for you like forget
about the business side where do you
want to spend your time
evan i really like writing and i really
like helping um people who who write
into me so i like the advice part of it
um so basically with me the blog is
great and interacting with people would
be great um you i think with the radio
part there's so much that goes into
radio i'm sure but i really like the the
internet part of it
so that's why
i wouldn't spend my time trying to
create local events and and do things
with local companies if that's not where
your heart is go online like keep the
blog going and then be all over social
media you know twitter facebook youtube
work on a radio show you can work on
your next book
you can get your interaction so like i
love that too i love helping
entrepreneurs uh it's it's it's hard to
do kind of one-on-one because
entrepreneurs don't have a huge budget
right you know we're
struggling to get our businesses going
they can't afford my rates uh but i get
interaction through my radio show
through
youtube videos i get hired to go and do
speaking around the world helping other
entrepreneurs conferences right like
that could be
your model
okay
that sounds great
okay yeah so the way i started this
maybe will help you is you know people
would write into me and ask me questions
right i'm sure people are already
writing to you your comments on the
blogs or people read your book and they
say hey andre you know i'm struggling
with this can you help me out
i would enjoy the interactivity and
write them back on the email because i
really want to help them but uh i turned
all of those into youtube videos
so instead of just answering you know
jamie's question for jamie you answer
jamie's question on a video and you know
jamie gets help but then lots of other
people you know thousands of other
people have that same question
also get help and you start building up
a brand and being known as the guy to
talk to about dating
okay okay that sounds good because um
like you were saying with the book i
mean with the the
the way the clever way i did i didn't
try to reinvent the wheel but i did put
a different spin on it that was just
interesting and if
you know and people like calling me like
what's my date number you know i'm like
well it's kind of i don't want to sign
you a date number just based upon the
book or whatever but it's a spark
discussion and i think that's what's
necessary in the dating community more
talking
and um so i just want to find a way to
do it and you know face-to-face is a
very good thing if i could do it on the
larger platform but
um like i said i just didn't really know
what to do when my publisher doesn't
know how to help me because i'm thinking
outside of the box
so
because this is not that outside of the
box this is more inside the blog like if
you look
you look at people who publish uh
non-fiction books who try to become
experts this is a very typical
model and what i would honestly do is
look at people who you look up to in in
other circles um
if it's an entrepreneur or self-help you
know maybe anthony robbins whoever it is
people who have kind of built what you
want to build in a different field and
look at the model that they took they're
all doing the same thing they have you
know the radio shows and the internet
shows and you know they're on social
media and they do speak gain and they
have info products and they're all doing
those models and
you know i would skew towards what you
like best if you like writing best then
then write more right like create the
blogs i prefer
talking and video so i spend most of my
time on the youtube channel and not uh
writing blog posts but that's a very um
it's a very common model for a lot of
speakers and experts and i think just by
modeling some of that success you can
find success for yourself and you know
apply your own little different andre
secret magic to it to kind of spin it in
your own method but um all of those
roots are you know kind of well
established there's whole industries
around them and you're in such a large
market that um you can have real impact
exactly thanks a lot you gave me a lot
to think about i took some notes based
upon what you told me so i have a clear
direction of where i want to go
i love it hey audrey when somebody
writes in on your blog or they write you
an email what what do you do somebody
says hey you know great blog posts i
have a question you know how do i find
my perfect match or whatever it is
how do you respond to a blog comment
basically when i get the black comment
goes to a
specified email address that i have set
up for and then i respond to that person
individually once they give me their
email address and contact so i write
them directly
okay so right there i would turn that
into a more public forum and maybe you
maybe you hide the person's name if it's
if that's a
you know personal issue
you know they don't want their name
being out there but you know now i only
write back to somebody
uh if i'll say i'll make a video
response for you which means i'll do a
video on my youtube channel for you and
so they're gonna benefit but but
now an audience benefits as well and so
if you take that and say either you know
i'll do a video for you but a video is
not your thing then you know i'll write
a blog post for you and and now what you
want to start doing is increasing your
output like how frequently are you
blogging
right now maybe like once
once a week i've shut it down i mean
when i first when i was first
establishing it it was more than that
but then i got caught up in doing other
things like with other businesses
helping my wife do whatever so i'm not
on it as much because when i noticed
that most of the audience were
international i just kind of lost
um i'm not going to lost faith but it's
like i'm like i don't know how to reach
these people i can't get in front of
them
you know it's growing but i don't know
how to connect with them
you know so i just wanna would you
rather write or do videos or do or do
audio what where are you leaning
i really like audio with the book the
next thing is to do like an audio an
audio block of people will respond to
listening and i don't mind video i'm
good at video as well so
um
that's the thing i mean all right
andre set up the schedule
okay you have your your once a week blog
post
and now you create a youtube channel
where
three times a week you're answering
questions from people
okay and anybody who writes in instead
of that personal response now it's ask
andre
and and they get a they get their
response through a youtube video that
then you start building a community
around and then you're gonna get more
questions like i have more questions
than i can answer you're gonna get more
questions on there people will leave
comments on your youtube and that like
publishers they want to see a platform
when you launch your next book you're
gonna have to change platform of people
from your blog from your twitter from
your youtube who will want to buy your
stuff because they've been following you
for the past year and engaging with your
stuff
okay
okay okay that sounds great that sounds
great that sounds great i've written it
down and i will apply it
yes and let me know keep me posted man i
want to hear about your progress
i sure will thanks a lot for all your
help
all right no problem andre hey for
everybody listening you know if you're
an expert you should be an exit of what
you do as entrepreneurs we should be
experts all of us at what we do
turn that into something you know let
people know about it show your
personality okay it's so important that
there's there's that personal connection
people can make to your business today
we're talking about sales we're talking
about growth and i'm super excited to
have one of the nation's top experts on
sales process on sales development sales
strategy the founder of curlin and
associates dave carlin dave welcome to
the program
thanks evan it's great to be here
okay so we've been talking entrepreneurs
about their their sales strategy their
pitch helping them grow and i know
they're the expert on it
what is the most important thing that
entrepreneurs need to do to be better at
selling
well the most important thing especially
in the context of talking about the
pitch is to stop pitching and start
listening
because invariably they're gonna pitch
the wrong thing at the wrong time to the
wrong person
whereas if they take a little time to
listen to the person they're pitching to
and find out what's going on with them
and what their issues are at worst they
can put that pitch into a context that's
meaningful for the person they're
pitching to and at best they can
customize it
and and make it the perfect solution to
whatever ails their prospect i i really
like that dave can you just give me two
how about that both of us like it
can can you i really want listeners to
understand that and i'm wondering if you
could bring it home maybe with a quick
example
sure
um so let's let's say that we're
pitching our new
uh technology we we designed this very
cool web application uh that does
something that's never been done before
and we can't wait to demo it we can't
wait to show it to people but because
it's a new technology that means people
would have to leave something they're
familiar with
and
move this way and there's great risk at
that there's discomfort with that
there's a learning curve more money
so the mistake entrepreneurs make is let
me give you a demo let's schedule a time
where i can demo it and they demo it and
the people go wow that's pretty cool
that's pretty interesting i'll let you
know if we're interested and they go
away
instead if they could take the time to
say you know we're helping companies
who've been frustrated because uh it's
taking too much time to populate these
their current
web screens with all this data that's
required and i was wondering if you had
a couple of minutes to talk about
the the repercussions uh all the time it
takes what it what it takes time away
from and what you could do if it didn't
require all those people to spend all
those hours doing all that remedial task
and if they can get a prospect talking
about that they can quantify
the problem it takes two extra people
30 hours a week and every single week to
keep this
current thing going and we pay those
people twenty dollars an hour
so two people sixty hours twenty dollars
an hour that's twelve hundred dollars a
week it's like sixty thousand dollars a
year we've been doing that for three
years it's 180 000 problem
cool
uh
would you be willing to to invest a
hundred dollars a month to make that
problem go away forever
yeah
okay now let me demo it and i'll show
you how you can save 60 hours a week two
people
and still end up with the same
outcome but easily automatically
programmatically automatic nice
so that's that's a generic example of
what i'm talking about so that the demo
is now customized it's in context we're
solving a specific problem instead of
bragging about what we developed i love
it so it's really kind of fun
to what are the pain points of the
company and then how can you customize
your pitch towards them i'm sorry it's
probably a problem on my end but the
last half of what you said cut out
oh okay well it's so it's really just
you know asking questions getting to
know the problems the pain points of
your prospect and then tailoring your
pitch and your presentation towards them
yes and i would add that even more than
pain points necessarily because not
everybody
has a pain point they want to spend
money on some people would rather bury
their head in the sand
it's got to be a compelling reason
it's true it's got to be a compelling
reason for them to spend money they
aren't currently spending or
if they're buying something like what
this entrepreneur has but they're buying
a different thing from a different
provider then
a compelling reason to move their
business to you
and it's got to be compelling enough to
cause them to take action or it'll just
be another one of those demos that you
did where somebody said cool
we'll let you know you know
entrepreneurs will often feel like okay
you know what i want to hire salesperson
you know i'm not maybe the greatest
salesperson myself i want to hire
somebody to do this for me when should
an entrepreneur go out and hire sales
staff
that's a great question
so if they're not a great salesperson
themselves
then they should their first hire after
uh technical people to build the product
should be a sales person the bigger
question is should that first sale tire
be a sales person a sales manager type
who can sell a little bit and then bring
on some sales people or the sales vp
who would be more strategic
and kind of build a sales organization
complete with systems and processes and
there is no
one correct answer to that it's a
scenario by scenario decision a lot of
it depends on how much money you have a
lot of it depends on what you need today
if today you need sales then a sales
person would be best if sales can come
next month then a sales manager might be
best and if sales can come
later in the year then the vp might be
best
got it now you also have tools to help
entrepreneurs figure out
you know am i a salesperson or not or
should i hire somebody right you have
kind of diagnostic tools to kind of dig
into the personality and characteristic
traits of people to see if they are
sales people
good memory we not only kind of have
those things we have the best on the
planet
so so how does that work so if i want to
you know i'm an entrepreneur i'm not
getting the sales i want and i'm worried
that you know it may be a personality
thing or maybe it's just a
you know a systems thing that i need to
get better at how would i be able to
find out if i'm meant to be a
salesperson or not
so it's probably not a personality thing
since personality has very little to do
with selling ability but it could be a
competency thing and it could be a sales
dna thing competency would involve the
skills that we bring to the table
for an entrepreneur there may be a lot
of gaps there and sales dna would be the
way we
feel and think about selling and how our
strengths would either support the use
of sales process sales strategy sales
tactics or
sabotage
our use of those things so we can
evaluate an entrepreneur
for their suitability and capability at
selling which can answer a whole bunch
of questions like can i get better at
this should i get better at this or is
it hopeless should i hire somebody
got it and then to get this test do i
where do i go do i go to your website
well we can go to a website go to uh
objectivemanagement.com
we could go to curlin associates.com
or you can just drop me an email and i
will connect you with the right person
and the email address would be
uh let's see the easiest one would be uh
dave
objective management
dot com
love it now if i decide okay you know
what i take the task i figure you know i
need to hire sales person how long does
it take for that person to round up and
start generating some money for me
another good question so you have to
allow 90 days just to find the sales
person because you can't compromise on
that first sales higher the most
important hire that you're going to make
so you've got to get that right we have
some tools that will help with that too
uh but for ramp up i'll give you a
formula so that you can calculate what
the ramp up needs to be
because that's going to be different for
every company too uh what you should
plan on one minute yeah one minute i can
do this
what you should plan on is length of
your sales cycle
that would be from when a prospect is
first interested until they pay
so
in months the length of your sales cycle
plus the length of your learning curve
how long it's going to take to teach
the new salesperson about your business
so that they can have an intelligent
conversation about it with a prospect
plus 30 days
so
at that point that's enough time to ramp
somebody up so that they're consistently
bringing in business assuming you hired
the right person and your product is a
good value
got it love it dave thank you so much
for joining us today for people who want
to find out more check out
curlingassociates.com
dave has some of the greatest
information online about sales again one
of the nation's top experts on sales
process sales development sales strategy
dave thank you so much for joining us
today
thanks for thinking of me and inviting
me it's great being with the nation's
top expert on entrepreneurs
i love it thanks dave
before we went to commercial break i
promised we would get to uri now and i
mispronounced his name so uri has been
on hold for a long time and i want to go
right to you where we where are you from
and how can i help
i love mr carmichael can you hear me
i can hear you where are you from
wonderful i am originally from israel i
currently live in milwaukee wisconsin
milwaukee all right how can i help yes
sir yes sir
i'll explain you this
when i was seven years old i moved to
the united states and i gave myself a
challenge to learn english and i did
just that now i know english when i was
14 years old i gave myself a challenge
to learn piano and i did just that now i
play piano when i was 18 years old i
gave myself a challenge to set a world
record and now i'm a
guinness world record holder and now i'm
21 years old and i'm looking to create a
film
and it's been the most difficult
challenging journey of my entire life
but i still plan on creating a film
and now
it essentially would be a film to
juxtapose
the youth that i grew up with uh with
the youth that i currently am surrounded
and
it's a film that would be called
israelika which is uh the hybrid of
israel in america and it'll be a film
that would be very very very powerful
form of public relations for israel
especially ever after everything they
went through this past summer
um and a lot of people have expressed a
lot of interest in it and the audience
wants it and there's a very strong
demand for it the only problem is
finding an angel investor and finding
someone who really wants to latch onto
the project and really i've gotten
compliments from people all throughout
the united states i've had soldiers in
the israeli defense force supported
which that in itself can get a lot of
media
and it's really just getting someone to
latch onto such a project is what i'm
struggling with so i'm looking for
advice
where to what's your world's gonna be in
it are you
are you in film or are you gonna be
producing it or what what's your role
going to be i'm more of a person who's
people of people have regarded me as
more of an artist you know i in the film
i plan on incorporating music which is
where the entrepreneurial mindset comes
in comes in story you know it would be
i'm over a producer and i would have
directors and
kind of business associates guiding me
through the whole journey um but i'm
more of the person with the creative end
of the project and now i need someone to
back the budget of such a project and i
have a business plan
and i have uh promotional videos
and so on that i've shared with people
and a lot of people have expressed
interest and shown a lot of support for
it but you know a lot of people
unfortunately don't always put their
money with their mouths you know they
say it's nice you know let me know if it
gets off the ground let me know if you
find that first investor then we'll talk
or something you know
yeah so i would do i would do two things
okay one your investor is probably going
to come from somebody within the
community so if it's uh if this is
talking about israel you know you're
probably going to get somebody who who
has strong ties to israel and you know
believes like you do that this video
needs to be out there so that's
that's probably going to be the person
who will invest it's not just a business
thing but there's also a passionate uh
understanding behind it a lot of times
though these people don't want to be
the only person there and there's kind
of no momentum built up beyond you know
you kind of turning your wheels trying
to get some energy into it i would look
at trying to get part of it uh crowd
crowd funded have you looked at
kickstarter.com
yeah yeah everyone tells me that i
started a gofundme account with a
similar kickstarter the problem is i set
myself a high budget because i think
this is it has a high value
i gave myself a value of twenty thousand
dollars
to raise
and i did not i was not successful by
any means i raised maybe three hundred
dollars and people tell me number one
you know i want to get a return on the
investment number two i'm not just going
to give you 18 20 you know i feel like
that's just a waste of money to go
towards this film what do you what are
you gonna do with twenty dollars towards
the film you know how is that going to
help anyway
and i understand i get where they're
coming from
the bottom line is i need someone
to put a substantial investment they
want to see something serious
before maybe they would support and give
little uh donations you know i still
that's a lot of money there's still a
lot of people so like you can raise
millions of dollars on kickstarter
people have done that before with
different projects it has to be
important enough and when people are
invested in kickstarter they're not just
they're not owning a piece of the
project they're not getting a return
right they're not an equity investor in
your business they're
they're getting
some
recognition they're feeling they're part
of the project a lot of them are you
know they're dollars at a time but then
you give them experiences or bonuses as
you go up and it's making those
experiences and bonuses interesting and
compelling enough that people want to be
a part of it but with kickstarter you're
not giving up an equity position in your
business but what that can do is help
fuel
interest from an angel investor right
like if you have a twenty thousand
dollar budget and if you can raise five
thousand dollars from kickstarter which
isn't that much money then
you could take that to someone and say
hey look look at all these people who
are behind it and even if they're only
contributing a dollar ten dollars twenty
dollars at a time then
it looks like there's a there's there's
a movement there's momentum there's like
people want this you say so when you
called in you said people want this is
the demand for this but then when you go
to you know kickstarter there's no
results like people aren't backing it up
even with a dollar so if i'm coming in
as an investor i'm skeptical but there's
actually domain for it so if you could
show me a little bit of demand if you
can raise 5000 kickstarter then it's a
lot easier for an investor to come on
board and fund the rest of it because
they see momentum and they see that
there's an audience and they feel like
when we get this out lots of people are
going to watch it and i'm going to get a
return on my investment
i see i see what you're saying the only
problem is
people don't like to invest in a film
even if it's someone that they like me
and whatnot
because in my opinion you know they
either want to support something like
you know there's a recent ebola outcase
you know people have supported that
recently that there's people with like
cancer that i mean people start these
like go fund these account point they're
very successful but a film for an
amateur film producer it's extremely
difficult to do that um just because
there's so many other things that they
could support so many other closets like
why should we support your project
everybody has dreams you know why it's
hard to help you this is your first
video too right your first video is
going to be harder to to fund in any of
the next ones that you do it's
definitely hard so that's why the person
has to have a strong attachment to the
cause
somebody who really cares about israel
and telling this story and they feel
like this story needs to be told that
that's the person you need and they
don't care about ebola they care about
israel and there are people who do care
about it but going to them now
is really risky and it's it's easy to
get a no whereas if you go to them with
some momentum behind you and say hey
look we've had 500 people support us and
they've given us five thousand dollars
to launch this thing up we need you to
come in for the rest it's a lot easier
to get their support
but you also have hey josh you're sorry
yeah you also have 500 people who are
uh who are keeping you accountable and
that makes you work harder to get it
going listen we gotta wrap up the show
if you want to email me the page you had
the kickstarter that'd be great and we
can continue this conversation offline i
want to thank daniela and josh you guys
are great producers thank you everybody
for tuning in and listening in i'll be
back in two weeks continue to believe
and i will see you soon